[Music]
let's go to Vegas there was drama for
Britney Spears last night after a man
rushed the stage and had Brittney
fearing for her life
[Applause]
[Music]
20 seconds was all it took before
celebration turned into fear Britney's
knees buckled and she asked if the man
who had rushed the stage had a gun the
suspect identified as 37 year old Jessie
Webb jumped on stage did a cartwheel and
started approaching Brittney he body
slammed the first security officer who
approached him ultimately backup dancers
helped take the man down one of them
tells et Brittney was crying backstage
she thought one of the dancers broke
their back protecting her oh my god you
came on food it all happened during
Britney's first night back at her Vegas
residency after nearly a three-month
hiatus earlier in the day she
instagrammed this shot captioning it
quote missed being on stage ready for
Vegas tonight I'm so excited to see you
all
et confirmed Webb was arrested for
trespassing not for possession of a gun
and was seen smiling in this mug shot
before he was ultimately ejected from
the concert Webb kicked a security guard
who then limped offstage and I witnessed
lzt the individual was acting rowdy all
evening
he was seen climbing over chairs and
security asked him to calm down several
times before he stormed the stage we
know concert venues have beefed up
security following ariana grande show in
May when a bomb killed 22 people
thankfully this situation had a much
different ending
Britney returned to the stage after five
minutes and finished the show man scary
stuff now Britney won't be back on the
stage until Friday in Vegas because she
usually gets the night off on Thursdays
and after seeing that I'm gonna say
right now she deserves a little break
[Music]
you